alors la situation à laquelle on va
s'intéresser aujourd'hui elle est un peu
différente des deux vidéos précédentes
sur l'effet doppler cette fois ci on va
considérer deux observateurs humains
qui se situe aux alentours d'un trou
noir
alors disons que cette sphère représente
un trou noir
de rayons de schwarzschild rs alors on
considère un trou noir statique dans la
métrique de schwarzschild et la métrique
s'écrit de cette façon ds 2 et gala
d'été deux
fois c'est 2-1 monterrey sur r
- dr 2 sur un air et sur r
- r2 fois défi de encore donner tes airs
fille alors ici on est sur une métrique
à deux dimensions des espaces la
troisième dimension n'est pas importante
car on peut toujours sera menée par
symétrie à un plan alors la métrique ici
de schwarzschild c'est ce qui permet de
décrire l'espace temps autour d'un trou
noir mais également autour d'un astre
statique comme la terre ce ferry quai
statique
et à partir de cette métrique on va
pouvoir calculer les produits scalaires
entre des vecteurs les normes des
vecteurs et donc faire le même
raisonnement que la dernière fois pour
le l'effet doppler relativiste mais dans
une géométrie d'espace-temps courbet
alors pour simplifier le contenu de
cette vidéo on va considérer que nos
deux observateurs restent immobiles dans
ses coordonnées c'est à dire que les
deux sont équipés d'une fusée qui leur
permet de garder une attitude constante
et donc de rester immobile par rapport
au trou noir alors bien entendu on
pourrait considérer que les deux
observateurs sont en mouvement ça
rajouterait un peu de complexité dans
les calculs mais pas tant que ça là les
sens du calcul ne changeraient pas et
donc pour simplifier pour que la vidéo
reste courte on va considérer uniquement
deux observateurs immobile
alors imaginons que cette première
personne s'appelle à cette deuxième
personne s'appelle b
et que la personne a en vous un rayon
lumineux
dans une certaine direction avec un
vecteur qu'on va appeler cas a
alors c'est un vecteur d'espace-temps
donc il faudra pas oublier de prendre en
compte sa composante temporel
le rayon lumineux est dévié par le trou
noir
et il arrive à la personne b avec un
vecteur cab est différent de caa
et c'est ici toute la la complexité qui
s'ajoute dans le cas d'un espace-temps
courbe par rapport à la version de la
relativité restreinte c'est que les
rayons lumineux peuvent être déviée et
donc le vecteur de départ est le vecteur
d'arrivée du rayon sont deux vecteurs
différents
une subtilité qu'il faudra également
prendre en compte c'est le fait que la
métrique cette fois ci contrairement à
la métrique de minkowski dépend de la
position où l'on se trouve on voit
qu'ici la métrique dépens de r c'est à
dire l'altitude par rapport au centre du
trou noir alors ce n'est ça ne
représente pas exactement l'attitude en
termes d'une longueur physique mais
c'est simplement une coordonnée qui
permet de se repérer dans l'espace et la
métrique dépend de cette coordonner ce
qui indique que l'espace temps n'est pas
plat et dépend en fait la courbure de
l'espace-temps dépend de la position
l'on se trouve et donc pour faire les
produits scalaires entre deux vecteurs
il faudra bien faire attention à prendre
la métrique à l'endroit où se trouvent
ces deux vecteurs
nos deux observateurs a et b ont
également un vecteur spatio-temporelle
qu'on va noter ua
et ib
mais comme on considère que ces deux
personnes sont immobiles dans l'espace
ces deux vecteurs sont uniquement
temporel est donc là je les représente
par des points pour indiquer que ce sont
des vecteurs qui sont uniquement dirigé
dans la direction du temps et la common
diagrammes et uniquement spatiale ces
vecteurs n'ont pas de dimension dans
l'espace
bon peut maintenant commencer le calcul
alors on a vu la dernière fois que la
fréquence
mesurée par un observateur par exemple
l'observateur a est égal au produit
scalaires entre le vecteur de l'ondh
alors ici c'est le produit scalaires
entre le vecteur d'onde quant à
avec le vecteur d'espace-temps de
l'observateur / sa norme
et il en va de même pour la fréquence
mesurée par b
et ici il faudra faire attention comme
je disais que les deux produits
scalaires ne se situe pas au même
endroit et donc la métrique qu'on va
utiliser le r qui intervient dans la
métrique sera un air différent et donc
on va noter ces deux aires ra et herbes
et
qui vont représenter donc l'altitude de
la personne à
et l'altitude de la personne d
alors ici les deux personnes ne sont pas
forcément sur un même axe on peut
imaginer que a est légèrement avec un
angle légèrement différent ou même que à
se situe ici en fait on verra que
l'angle ne compte pas puisqu'il ya une
grandeur qui est conservé le long de la
géodésie suivi par le rayon lumineux et
ça nous permet de faire un calcul dans
le cas général
alors maintenant qu'on a ces deux
expressions ici on peut essayer
d'exprimer les vecteurs hué cas alors
les deux vecteurs ua et hub et valent
tous les deux un
0-0
dans les coordonnées tr fille
puisque les deux observateurs se déplace
uniquement dans la direction du temps
alors on peut calculer tout de suite la
norme de ces deux vecteurs la norme de
ua
c'est la racine carrée et là on applique
la métrique alors on voit que les deux
composantes rfi sont nuls donc on va
uniquement s'intéresser à ce terme de la
métrique d'été ici représente la
composante ici qui vaut 1 et donc d'été
vos seins et donc c'est simplement la
racine carrée de ces carrés x 1 - rs sur
erre ici le r comprend c ra
puisque on calcule la norme du vecteur
ua qui est située en a
de même la norme du vecteur hub et pas
besoin de refaire le calcul c'est la
même chose mais avec un moins rs sur rbe
est
alors à partir du moment où on a ça on
pourrait directement remplacer les
vecteurs ici
mais la difficulté ici ça va être
d'exprimer caa et kb
puisqu'on voit que ce vecteur les deux
vecteurs cas et kb doivent être reliées
par une géodésique de type lumière c'est
à dire le la forme du rayon lumineux ici
qui est déviée par le trou noir et on
aimerait donc trouvé une relation qui
permet de relier k b et k
alors qu'à et kb sont deux vecteurs donc
on peut leur donner des composantes
donner des noms à leurs composantes et
on verra par la suite que seule la
première composante la composante
temporel est importante puisque ce qui
compte ici dans les calculs ce sont les
deux produits scalaires de cas avait qu
à et usb et de kb s b et ses produits
scolaires ne faut intervenir que la
composante temporel puisque ea et eb
sont des vecteurs purement temporel et
que la métrique et diagonale donc on va
oublier ces deux composantes là et ne
s'intéresser qu'à la composante
temporelle des vecteurs cas
alors ici on va décider d'appeler ces
deux composantes oméga à et oméga b
alors bien entendu le nom n'a pas
d'importance c'est juste pour leur
donner un nom et à partir d'ici on
aimerait trouver une relation entre
oméga b et oméga pas alors pour faire ça
on va remarquer que la métrique ne
dépend pas du temps alors effectivement
la métrique de schwarzschild qui décrit
ce trou noir est invariante par rapport
au temps et les statiques et donc on a
par le théorème de notaire comme il y à
une symétrie dans la métrique on a une
grandeur qui sera conservé le long de la
géodésie suivi par le rayon lumineux
et en particulier cette grandeur qui est
conservé c'est la dérive et de ce dsk
ray ici
par rapport à d'été puisque ici on
regarde quelle est la grandeur conservé
par rapport à la dimension temporelle
puisque c'est l'invariance par rapport
au temps qu'on utilise
alors si on effectue ce calcul la dérive
et de cette expression par rapport à dt
alors on voit que ces deux termes
n'interviennent pas
et on obtient simplement ce terme si
dérivés la dérive et de dt caresser 2dt
fois ce terme ici c'est carré 1 - et
rassurer
et le théorème de nos terres nous dit
que cette grandeur est une grandeur qui
est conservé et donc cette grandeur si
on remplace d'été ici par oméga à ou par
oméga b cette grandeur aura la même
valeur si on remplace du coup
respectivement airs par ra et r b et
donc on peut écrire une équation qui va
relier oméga et oméga b alors le de ici
et le ccar et ne sont pas importants
puisque ce sont deux constantes
et donc en remplaçant les 6 dt par oméga
on obtient oméga à facteur de 1 - rs sur
air à
ça c'est cette grandeur calculé en a et
d'après le théorème de notaire on sait
qu'elle est égal à oméga des facteurs de
1 - rs sur rb
cette équation ici c'est l'équation
vraiment crucial dans le calcul qui nous
permet de relier et bien le vecteur kb
aux vecteurs cas
et à partir de là on va pouvoir finir
notre calcul
donc pour finir notre calcul on aimerait
calculer les produits scalaires caha
avec ua et kb avec ubp est donc le
produit scalaires de cas et ua
alors qu'a eu assez simplement un 0 0
donc c'est uniquement la première
composante qui nous intéresse c'est à
dire la composante oméga et ici il faut
faire attention à bien utiliser la
métrique appliquée en a et donc on a des
thés carré alors ceux d'été carré se
scinde en deux on a un x oméga a donc
ces oméga à
facteurs de ces carrés
x 1 - rs sur era
et pour bébés pour kb point ubc
exactement la même chose
et on obtient oméga b
fois c'est carré fois un mois et reste
sur rb
et là on peut tout de suite remplacé
cette expression là
en identifiant que omega b ici à partir
de cette équation oméga avait donné par
oméga facteur de 1 mois et reste sur era
/ 1 - harvest sur rbe est
donc oméga b est égal à oméga x 1 - rs
sur era
sur 1 - rs sur rbe et
est ensuite facteurs de ces carrés fois
un mois et reste sur herbe est
ici les deux termes ça nul et on obtient
que ce produit scalaires vos simplement
oméga c'est carré facteur de 1 - rs sur
era
c'est dire que ce produit scalaires vaut
exactement la même chose que cas points
et à
et ça en fait cette remarque elle n'est
pas anodine en fait on aurait pu partir
directement de cette remarque le fait
que le produit scalaires de huê cas
reste constant le long de la géodésie qu
ça vient simplement du fait que les
vecteurs eu correspondent aux vecteurs
temporel et comme le vecteur temporel
représente une symétrie de la métrique
puisque la métrique ne varie pas au
cours du temps et bien cette grandeur
d'après le théorème de notaire doit être
conservé en fait on dit plus précisément
que les vecteurs eu ici représente un
champ de vecteurs de killing c'est à
dire en fait une symétrie de l'espace
temps et donc que le produit scalaires
du vecteur d'onde ici qui suit une
géodésique doit avec le vecteur de
killing doit être constant
est donc maintenant qu'on a identifié ça
on peut calculer le rapport entre la
fréquence reçu par b et la fréquence
émises par a
ici du coup la fréquence reçu par b ckb
point hub et
sur la norme de hub et
le tout / f à c'est à dire / k a point
eu un
fois eu la norme de juin
et si on a vu que ces deux termes sont
égaux et donc en fait le rapport des
fréquences c'est le rapport des normes
des deux vecteurs temporel qui vaut
alors la norme de l'ua c'est ça et on
voit ici que les deux ces carrés vont
s'annuler donc je vais pas les écrire
c'est simplement la racine carrée de 1 -
rs sur herbe
sur un mois rs sur prb
et cette équation c'est l'équation
finale de l'effet doppler dans la
métrique de schwarzschild pour deux
observateurs immobile qui s'échangent un
rayon lumineux
donc ce qu'on peut observer ici c'est
que si l'observateur par exemple disons
l'observateur en b se situe très loin du
trou noir
ici ce terme tend vers zéro puisque rb
est très grand et donc ça devient
approximativement 1 - rs sur era ce qui
est inférieur à 1 c'est à dire que
l'observateur en b va recevoir londe
avec une fréquence qui est décalée vers
le rouge une fréquence plus faible et
donc si l'observateur a aimé une onde
l'observateur bva voir l'observateur a
plus rouge décaler vers le rouge est
également il va l'observer au ralenti
c'est ce qu'on appelle la dilatation du
temps gravitationnelle
et dans l'autre sens si cette fois ci
c'est l'observateur à qui reçoit l'ondh
donc on s'intéresse à linverse de ce
rapport cette fois ci le rapport sera
supérieur à 1 et donc l'observateur a
qui reçoit lé ondes émises par b
observant une onde décaler vers le bleu
et il verra l'observateur b évolué en
accéléré
donc si on résume avec des couleurs
6b du coup et plus loin comme indiqué
sur ce diagramme londres reçu par b
semble redshift est décalée vers le bleu
et londres reçu par a envoyé par b
semble blue shift est décalée vers le
bleu